what's that believe nation its Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in
people more than they believe in
themselves and my sincere hope is that
if you see in you what I see in you
you'll be able to change the planet I
started the mentum II series with the
goal to try to learn from people who've
done a lot more than us try to hang out
with people who have had more success in
us and hopefully some of their beliefs
some of their mindset some of their way
of working seeps into us to help us
become the best version of ourselves so
today we're gonna learn from Floyd
Mayweather and Carter McGregor and their
motivation also as you're watching if
you hear something that really resonates
with you please leave it down in the
comments below I put quotes around it so
other people can be inspired by it as
well and if you leave it within the
first couple hours of this video going
live you have a chance to win one of two
daily prizes
[Music]
you
do you remember the first time that the
thought of fighting Floyd Mayweather
crossed your mind it's been it's been on
my radar for a long long time and as a
as a young man coming up in the game and
in the sport of MMA I was listening to
him in similar weight class similar
weight category speaking ill of the
sport speaking ill of the discipline and
as a young kid I'm looking at him in
such a high level saying saying these
things about the sport that I'm
dedicating my entire life doing thinking
I'll see you for that one day why are we
getting ready to watch Floyd money
Mayweather in the ring against Conor
McGregor August 26 man huh just what the
world demanded I put myself in the right
position to make it happen so I put
myself in the right position to make it
happen
it's all about chess and it's not really
about being on a chess board anymore
it's about controlling the chessboard
and you know that's what I was able to
do did you want this fight or did you
respond to somebody who wanted you
actually I asked for the fight I think
it was kind of mutual
you know I think I wanted to fight
pretty sure he wanted to fight I don't
think in the beginning Dana White
thought the fight could happen
but we're here now you wanted to fight
why not just because that's what the
people wanted I know I got that answer
but if I could put myself in a position
to make nine figures why not why not so
I put myself in a position I wants to
get there would never be a fighter
that's on my level because you have to
be able to go where I go mentally you
have to deal my level mentally and I and
it's hard for anybody dealing my level
mentally because I think outside the box
that's why I'm always doing
record-breaking numbers that's why
mommy's doing record-breaking things
that's always able to go on Dancing with
the Stars and take chances and go on WWE
and steal fans from the WWE and steal
Affairs from Dancing with the Stars and
take chances to become a household name
to become a pay-per-view star to become
a mega superstar to have the biggest
deal in sports history
how roll the dice I take chances when
you hear boxing aficionados like Max
Kellerman say you're not gonna lend a
punch how do you react to that the
people like today we posted videos of
you hitting the bag and it's all people
saying look how slow he is he doesn't
know what he's doing
look at this movement stuff do you enjoy
that yeah better you know it happens to
to all all great straining methods try
everything is criticized and I mean
originally Floyd way back his method of
hitting the pods and him the bag was
ridiculed join them the Hatton builder
when I first kind of start seeing about
fluid they ridiculed his methods and
then all of a sudden everyone starts
trying to follow his methods you know I
mean went on to success this is it's
been the same with me when I started
incorporating movement train and I
started incorporating attacks and saying
approaches in the mixed martial arts
game ridiculed it's a joke
a joker as well how many times have been
called a joke or a joker and then
everyone starts following and trying to
study it's it's no different here the
boxing game I look oh he doesn't he
doesn't move this way what's he doing
this that and the other they just don't
understand I mean they don't understand
they just try and discard it but
thankfully August 26th there can be no
running from it so it will the same
thing that will happen that always
happens we will try and push it away it
will face it will be put in front of
them Floyd will be slept and then they
will begin the studying process and then
they were and then the implementing
process and then I'm on to the next
which is what I'm on to my next wave of
preparation so they're here and I'm here
again and then I'm here and then I'm
here gender so I'm saying yeah so that's
it that's it that's that's that's like a
man that has never been in a boxing ring
is in the ring with the best ever that's
what you talk that's what you describe
yourself as being I don't ascribe myself
we must realize men like women line
numbers don't lie 49 and oh not just 49
listen I mean whether that's didn't
didn't broke every record in boxing when
we get to talk about highest gate even
it was like right now they said off
mayweather fight didn't sell oh well you
know woman when they do sell out I think
I read somewhere like you know that live
gated reached like 80 some million for
this fight already we already had 60
something million for those are saying
that Mayweather is not doing numbers
anymore far as taking the less
punishment I took less punishment there
any fighter not just best defense let's
talk about offense the most accurate
fighter of all time on outside the ring
it's not just about being inside the
ring re already conquered that I was I'm
even smarter on the outside you know I
have to be a genius to even make this to
even make a fight like this happen so
what what does that say about me for
making this it says that your it says
that you're a brilliant businessman not
just a great box so that and that's what
I always spoke about that's what I
always spoke about I gave my credit
about what I do in the ring but I don't
get my credit about what I do on the
outside are you I mean you're enjoying
great riches and success now but can you
put yourself in the mindset of
guy who's waiting in line with other
people always I'm you remember what that
guy pays are you daydreaming of this was
that even possible of every day I was
daydreaming but of course I can go back
and think they're gone that's I I lived
there in my inner man I always be there
you know I show up on work every single
day like I'm not in the position on me
like I'm not me so that's the mindset I
haven't it's it's workin you got
fighters there may be faster than me you
got fighters they make it harder than me
you got fighters that's very athletic
but you don't have no fighter that can
make adjustments like me you don't have
fires that could be on my level
mentally it's never personal for me it's
always business every every other
fighter fight for certain things
everybody fight though what they fight
for my thing is this I keep my eyes on
the prize
I never focus on things outside the ring
my focus does the guy that's in front of
me you get to what you're trying to get
to by staying focused standing on a
parallel path I'll always have a dream
and my dream was to be the best no
matter what happens Saturday when it
comes down to boxing I'm the best at
this what do you think they'll say about
you in 50 years you know I'm not quite
sure what they say about me I'm just
saying they probably just said man I'm a
young kid who showed up when he said he
was gonna show up and that's it so I I
don't know I don't think about that when
you walk in here with the I just I just
what I do know is and I just know that
it will live on that's what I do know I
I cannot control what people say about
me now or in the future but I said you
know what I am doing and the stuff that
I've done and achieved will live on long
after I'm gone as you've been away from
the game and you reflect on your life in
your career right now
yes where are you just looking at the
life of Floyd Mayweather just looking at
my life I don't think most people can
handle he had to be into my shoes
yo-yo I don't think it's for me that's
right now I don't think no one can
handle my situation why not they just
can't
what's the situation that can't be
handled I'm saying it's like I mean they
feel like it's pressure on me I mean
like I say they try to defeat me in many
different ways
they try to bring up the tax thing they
try to bring up he's being locked up
I mean he's arrogant he's I don't
appreciate any years and years and years
they've been trying their best to defeat
me mentally I can't be defeated
I'm a strong individual nothing can
throw me off
nothing throwing me off throw me off key
I'm always focused on what I got to do
and that's gonna be the case August 26th
I was 26 gonna be really interested like
I said and I'm not backing up remember I
told you that you're not backing up I'm
not backing up
[Music]
when I was a kid he's always visualized
Stadium something and like even when I
was playing football I'd kick the ball
against a wall and I don't pretend that
I scored a goal and I'd run off and I'd
be raising my hand and visualizing a
arena full of fans so some I don't as a
kid out on my own I like just running
around kicking the ball I always had
these visions of something but I just
didn't know what it was and then I
suppose when I came to this these events
I know it stopped raining and then came
to an event I was like okay this is it
this is this is what I'm gonna do and
then now I'm dealing but did you ever
have let's call it a normal job Connor a
nine-to-five
yeah because the artist thing is the
games were trade straight away him I was
no different
soon as I finished school I was always
getting pests with what are you doing
with your life and then they still not
and they didn't know what it was they
didn't know if MMA wasn't know what none
of this didn't know it can make a career
out of as far as they were concerned me
mind I'm talking about as far as they
were concerned of just getting into a
cage appointment some other guy they
didn't know nothing about it
no one did really but I knew and I mean
I knew well that and then I got it I end
up getting a trade just to keep them
quiet
zhuzi I had a lot of fights with me
dial-up when trade did you get I end up
getting a trade as a plumber how bad was
a problem yeah horrendous were you
actually in the trenches I mean it was
an industrial so I'd be like building
this it'd be like diploma that would be
needed
place like this six o'clock in the
morning and the motorway and I used to
have to walk through an hour to get them
to get there on motorway and then I
stand on the edge of the motorway and
wait for a bloke to drive boy so give me
a lift and then the motorway was like a
renovation at the time so take me to or
two now if I was to get to the place was
out in the country gonna be there for
ten hours walking and I was a first-year
so as the worst of the war sermons on
the beginning then two hours to get back
in the traffic again which is a horrible
horrible time and I was like you know
what I don't want to deal with this and
then I just left I lasted 18 18 months
tell me what was tough you know just
like it wasn't always on the life of me
and then and then John said because I
was training with John as well at the
time and then John got on Twitter says I
have a show on the show would like to
fight honey and then that was he I just
packed it in didn't show up weed I used
to come in and punch the head on me and
like try and drag me out Beth and I just
wouldn't go and I mean had Oprah off for
a good few years with him all verbal and
and that was he I just packed it in quit
and then focus on training that's I knew
I knew I knew what was gonna happen I
knew I was gonna get here they didn't
there's a lot of stressful years a lot
of times and well I proved them wrong I
proved myself right but everything I do
in my life is is related to this
I don't think nothing else maybe it's
enough
fine I mean and that that is why and I
mean to be true so nearly all you gotta
do is show is that that unhealthy I
don't know
do I look unhealthy take a look at this
physique I'm in phenomenal shape in body
and mind to me what's unhealthy is
living an unhealthy life to me what's
unhealthy is getting up and gone to the
same day every day I like 9:00 to 5:00
in an office or in it
god that's unhealthy that beats your
mind I don't I don't work I what about
love what I do and that's why I'm doing
what I love you know I mean that's right
that's why it's become a career for me
because I love it I love what I do thank
you guys so much for watching I hope you
enjoyed I'd love to know what did you
learn from this video what clip spoke
the most to you and how are you going to
apply it immediately somehow in your
life or in your business please leave it
down the comments below also if you're
leaving a comment within the first few
hours of this video going live you have
a chance to win one of two daily prizes
I also want to give a quick shout out to
Luis Lopez from the better men project
Luis thank you so much for picking up a
copy of my book your one word and doing
the review on your YouTube channel I
really really really appreciate this
apartment and I'm so glad you enjoyed my
book if you could describe yourself with
one word what would it be
thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
I'll see you soon